hey guys welcome to our video about
lenses a lot of you guys have asked what
kind of lens should i get what kind of
lenses you have how does the lens work
i'm gonna answer all that and more in
this video
[Music]
so you can spend all the money you want
on a good camera but at the end of the
day your camera is only as good as the
lens you're using because that's what's
actually taking your image and putting
it on the sensor or film if you're one
of those old-school type of people
so i'm going to tell you a little bit
about what makes good lens
and a little bit about the kind of
lenses that we actually have lenses are
built into every camera we use these
days so much so you might not even think
about what the purpose of a lens
actually is because you can't just take
a sensor and point it at the world all
you get is a big blur you actually need
to take the light and focus it to
actually get a crisp image that's how
your eyes work that's how cameras work
so the way a lens is built it's not just
one piece of glass it's actually many
pieces of glass because you have focus
at different distances some lenses are
zoom lenses you have the ability to
change focal distance some lenses even
have image stabilization which actually
removes vibration from the shot so
there's a lot of elements inside of a
lens and that's why they can get kind of
expensive with all those pieces of glass
inside the actual way the lens is built
plays a very significant role in the
quality of the lens you want smooth easy
turns
for smooth focus pulling and smooth
zooming should you have a zoom lens so
when you're picking out a range of
lenses for your camera basically there's
three things you want to cover you have
wide angle lenses mid-range lenses and
telephoto lenses what does that mean you
get lenses that are wide angle lenses
that you see a very wide angle of your
subject or the room or whatever it is
that you're shooting much like your eyes
you can almost see 180 degrees with your
eyeballs now telephoto lenses are the
opposite of that they seem to take the
subject and put it really close to the
viewer basically the lens is doing the
same thing of taking your image and
cropping it in until you have just a
subject that might be far away but they
feel the frame so basically a wide angle
lens makes things seem far away a
telephoto lens makes things seem close
you know those shots of like the moon or
eagles those are shot with the telephoto
lens because you can't get too close to
a lion and then there's also mid-range
lenses which are not super wide and not
super telephoto and those are good like
all around purpose lenses when you just
have to kind of like run and gun and
figure it out when you get there now
there's also another type of lens called
a prime lens a prime lens does not have
the ability to zoom it's a simpler build
and they can actually usually make
better lenses for cheaper you just lose
the ability to customize on the spot
what your framing is like you can with
the zoom lens a lens also has iris
control many old lenses and many nikon
lenses have manual iris control where
you can actually control the amount of
light coming into the camera by opening
and closing an iris inside the lens but
a lot of lenses like canon lenses are
actually electronically controlled for
the iris so you actually need a camera
that can talk to the lens electronically
and you adjust it with the camera the
better the lens and usually the more
expensive the lens the more open this
aperture can get to let in more light
now the aperture is measured with
something called an f-stop and it's a
number like f 2.8 f 5.6
what that means is it's a ratio between
the focal length of the lens and how
open the aperture is basically this lens
is a 50 millimeter lens and the f-stop
is a ratio to how much it opens up so an
f-stop of two is basically 50 divided by
two so if i have this open to f2 that
means the aperture is 25 millimeters
open on a 15-millimeter lens so that's
what those numbers mean now the thing is
engineers face a tricky issue with
aperture when you start to open the
aperture more and more you start to use
more and more of the glass and the lens
it gets really hard to keep the image
crisp and sharp so generally speaking
the better lenses can open further but
they also cost a lot more money because
they need to use much more precise glass
and much more precise mathematics to
actually make the lens work so these
lenses open up to 2.8 on the other hand
a prime lens because it's not a zoom
lens it doesn't have all those fancy
moving parts it's easier to actually
have the aperture open up further so we
have two prime lenses because our
scarlet camera is not that great in low
light this one opens up to 1.4 and this
one opens up to 1.4 that's a lot more
light than 2.8 so the next thing that
makes a good lens is sharpness now you
might think that all lenses are all
sharp because most pictures just look
sharp all the time but that's not
actually true especially as you look
towards the edge of a picture most
lenses are sharp kind of in the center
but as you get to the corners of your
picture you'll start to see things get
blurry and distorted good lenses don't
do that cheap lenses tend to do that now
the thing is you can get sharp images
out of almost any type of lens by using
a certain range of the f-stop because
when you close down the aperture it
actually focuses light a little bit
along with the glass now the range of
about 5.6 to f11 is about the range
where you get the sharpest image when
you go more open than that
the aperture doesn't influence the light
at all and doesn't focus it and when you
go more close than that the aperture
actually is closed down so far it
actually starts to diffract light
because of the edges of the iris bending
light a little bit as it passes through
it's kind of crazy you have a couple
other things that dictate a good lens
the first thing to look for is chromatic
aberration chromatic aberration is
basically a kind of rainbow fringing you
get on the edge of your picture
now generally speaking it's something
you don't want you want a crisp clear
picture all the way to the corners of
your image you don't want to get
all rainbowy and refracted at the edges
and the reason why that happens because
light in the rainbow
has a different wavelength when it's
down in the red versus when it's up in
blue and so a lens does not refract all
light to the same degree so red light
becomes refracted a little bit whereas
blue might become refracted a little bit
more and that's why it starts to
separate at the edges so good lenses
through the use of coatings and various
types of glass are able to avoid this
cheaper lenses start to show it now also
some cheap and old lenses out there tend
to get a little bit distortion it
actually like bulges in the center it
almost has like a pin cushion effect or
pinched effect generally it's not a huge
issue but if you're looking like on ebay
or craigslist for lenses just keep an
eye out for that kind of stuff so one of
the coolest features about modern lenses
is image stabilization basically inside
the lens is a little gyroscope and
computer that is keeping track of how
you're moving and wobbling and vibrating
because that's what we as human beings
tend to do when we hold cameras they
actually take that little lens and they
have it vibrate in the opposite
direction and it takes your image and
stabilizes it onto the sensor now for
people like me and sam who shoot
handheld that's a total life saver it
takes your shots that are all vibrating
and shaky and makes them smooth
it's really cool it feels like i'm in
the future so our two lenses here have
image stabilization because these lenses
we can zoom in a bit and as you zoom in
you start to exaggerate the shakiness of
your handheld
abilities a wide angle lens
tends not to show shakiness too much so
we don't have any image stabilization on
this one
hey before i tell you guys what lenses
you should have let me tell you what it
means when i read off all these numbers
all right so usually i'll say the type
of lens this is a tokina what kind of
mount does it have is a canon mount a
canon ef mount to be precise so when i
say this is a tokina 11 to 16 2.8 i'm
saying is it's tokina lens
11 to 16 millimeter zoom 2.8 minimum
aperture our main go to lens mid-range
lens this is a canon 17-55 2.8 this is a
canon 70-200 2.8
with image stabilization this is a sweet
lens
it's our most expensive lens i would
hate to drop it then over here we have
two primes that give us better low-light
capabilities this is a 50 millimeter 1.4
and over here we got the 24 millimeter
1.4 this is more for our wide-angle
shots that we need a lot of low-light
capabilities on we can open up really
far by the way there's a 50 millimeter
out there that cannon makes that goes to
1.8 that's still pretty good it's only
100 bucks if you guys are looking for a
good prime lens check it out also a lot
of you guys are saying why are you guys
using that crappy kit lens on your
scarlet
this isn't a crappy kit lens we did our
online research this is a 1755 2.8 this
is a great lens
look it up it's super sharp
don't give us crap about our lenses i
like my lenses
so at the end of the day there's a lot
of options out there with lenses and
they can be kind of expensive but don't
be discouraged there's a lot of great
used lenses that are out there if you're
looking for some good stuff check out
craigslist check out ebay try to do a
little bit of research beforehand
websites like thedigitalpicture.com
have awesome reviews with great photo
comparison so you can actually see what
each lens brings to the table and how
they compare with each other i highly
recommend you guys check it out
pick what works play with it don't be
afraid to use bad lenses
they still give cool images it's not the
end of the world your cameras come and
go but your lenses stay
these lenses we will have for a very
long time and the quality of their
picture will never change
peace out
you